while the defense department says
that the nuclear enterprise is the
number one thing their actions don't
display
that's the way it is if the united
states were to get rid of its nuclear
weapons it would basically be subject to
coercion
by russia by china because of the
presence of nuclear weapons
some of the most recent ones are
actually intellectually dishonest
the people in washington dc don't
actually
understand national security in the way
that they should they say we don't need
the missiles
we have enough nuclear weapons
in other systems we talked about this
that i think we make the mistake of
thinking that
other nations see things the same way we
do we have plenty of evidence that they
don't
they don't look at the same thing
welcome back to the generally speaking
show today we have
joe scallarns he's from missouri and
he's again we're going to talk a little
bit about the strategic
deterrent coalition but before we get
started
i'd like joe if you could just introduce
yourself to the generally speaking
audience
give us some of your background
how you got involved with strategic
deterrent coalition i think they'd be
interested to
understand your role advising the chief
of staff of the air force and how you
came to do that
i think it's an interesting story and i
think it's a a role that people
aren't really aware of so if you
wouldn't mind just
introducing yourself to the audience
all right well thanks rob i uh
i was a banker in missouri for
uh many years and
during the 90s
uh actually uh
about the time that the b-2 came to
whiteman air force base
i was a friend of ike skelton who was
the
longtime congressman and eventually
became
chairman of the house armed services
committee
and i was on a banking trip to d.c
having lunch with ike in the
capitol dining room and we
were talking about various things in the
state within the district
and he said are you
involved in this support group
over at whiteman air force base and i
said well no i'm
i'm not he said well you should be and
he told me a bit about it
and uh i said well i'll uh
i'll consider it i think that was on
like a thursday or friday
about the middle of the next week i got
a call from some major at white button
that said we understand
that you want to get involved and and
so i accept me up for that so i started
uh by um
visiting with we had a new commander at
the time at the
at the wing and i thought i could be of
some help to him
uh in his relationships with
the civilian community surrounding the
base so that's
kind of how i got started and after
a couple of years i was invited to serve
on the air combat command
commander's group that was called at the
time and it was a group of civic leaders
from the various bases within the air
combat command
and we met on a periodic basis
usually at langley but sometimes we go
on
on trips to see other parts of the arab
air force and get a good understanding
of what the command was doing
and then after a few years of that
general keys was the command of our
combat command
and he recommended me for a new group
that then
chief of staff of the air force
buzz mosley had organized and it was the
air force chief of staff civic leaders
group
and so in the second year of its
existence i
i went on that group and and that group
is just like civic leaders at local
bases
uh they become um
trusted friends and advisors to the
commander
this is the best way i could describe it
and
as uh his generals would
give him their best military advice
his civic leaders would give him their
best
civilian advice and uh
that that has continued
and i've i've served full terms
on uh that group and now continue to
serve as
an emeritus member which means i don't
go to all the events but i do get
invited to
uh annual events and some some trips
uh with the chief staff the air force or
the vice chief
so that's uh kind of how i got my
in involvement with the as a
civic leader for the air force
well as you know from your experience
the strategic
deterrent the nuclear enterprise
underwent some problems um
started with what was referred to as the
minot incident
where uh some nuclear weapons though not
armed but
nuclear weapons were in fact transported
uh from one base minot air force base
in north dakota to barksdale air force
base in louisiana
without them realizing that nuclear
weapons were on board and of course
proper protocols weren't followed
as it turned out uh you know
the mistake was discovered and corrected
and
and but it drew attention to the fact
that we become complacent within the
nuclear enterprise
uh in our national defense and uh
we let our guard down and did not
uh uphold the uh high standards that
would set for itself
within the enterprise
so um as a result of that
uh chief of staff at that time
general schwartz uh
created a staff position assistant chief
of staff for
nuclear deterrence and matters
the a10 and
they also put in motion
the to create a new command to
get the uh nuclear enterprise
out of air combat command where it had
been put
at the end of the cold war
and created the air force global strike
command
which was then to become the air force
element of u.s
strategic command
so i was fired by general will fraser
as a civic leader of our combat command
because
my base went to a new command and
lieutenant general frank klotz was the
first commander of air force
global strike command and he asked me to
serve on that civic leaders group which
i did and still do so
there's kind of the background of my
involvement as an
air force civic leader this led to
i guess it was about um
uh well as as as
the air force global strike command
started to develop um
the civic leaders realized that
we didn't really have a voice in public
discourse
about that element of our defense
you know there are all sorts of
organizations
that support the fighter community there
are all sorts of organizations that
support the logistics community there
was no one really
standing up for the strategic deterrence
or the nuclear part
it's kind of like at one of our
symposium the uh defense out of shae
from denmark
said uh they in denmark they really
appreciated the nuclear umbrella that
the united states provided for them and
they understood the whole
structure of strategic deterrence
but they just didn't want to talk about
it and i think
that's kind of the way that we were uh
during uh
well for the last 15 years
almost 30 years we went without talking
about it
uh and so now
uh we were in a situation where we were
talking about it but nobody
knew much what they were talking about
and as you know it's it's very difficult
to advocate for something that's
complicated and especially something
that's complicated and a good deal of
its classified
so people have a tendency to either over
complicate the discussion or
oversimplify the discussion
and there were a few of us
at that time that felt we we need to
have a voice of reason
in the public discourse
about that time we were hearing
all sorts of things being published and
said
by global zero an organization
that is flatly against nuclear weapons
of any kind
and they published a report
which they implied was a
government-sponsored report which it
wasn't
and and implied that it was
some sort of a scientific uh and
based on solid information which it
wasn't
but they had the ability to secure a lot
of endorsers
a lot of famous names who said yeah this
makes sense we can have a world without
nuclear weapons
so uh here again
a group of us said you know this is
silly
uh you know why why can't we uh
why can't we publicize the truth about
what's
what's going on here why can't we
actively support and endorse
a major milima element of our national
defense
so a group of civic leaders as i just
described
got together i believe uh
once in december of 2013
then in the spring of 2014 we got
together in dc
and um decided that we would
create an organization and then we went
through
the process of creating a not-for-profit
uh 501c3
educational organization
and uh if
was during during that year that we got
organized we got our
tax exempt status
approved and then
we had our i guess it was in may
of 2014 uh was it 14 or 15.
um it was may of 2015
that we had our very first symposium and
this is interesting because we had it
in warrensburg missouri which you know
but
most people don't know is pretty small
town right adjacent to
whiteman air force base in west central
missouri
so all my friends in washington dc and
in new york said we could never do it
it would never happen but we
did succeed in having a national
symposium
in warrensburg missouri in that year
and and i was i was happy to be one of
the speakers featured speakers at that
symposium and at the time i was working
the joint staff for the chairman of the
joint chiefs
looking at u.s china competition and the
result of a lot of that work
i publish in a book called stealth war
now one of the key
principles in that book is the idea that
nuclear weapons have forced warfare
into the public domain using the
internet using our companies using
our universities our political system
against us
the chinese communist party has sought
to undermine our society from within
and one of the main reasons is because
the price the cost to china and the
united states of direct
armed conflict is too high precisely
because
of the existence of nuclear weapons so
the people you talk about the global
zero
don't acknowledge the fact that their
plan
requires uh the soviet union
former soviet union russia and china
to get rid of their nuclear weapons uh
and other countries like north korea and
iran
and well iran doesn't have but india
and of course we know that um getting
those authoritarian regimes to get rid
of their nuclear weapons
is going to be almost impossible
moreover
if if the united states were to get rid
of its nuclear weapons it would
basically be subject to coercion
by russia by china because of the
presence of nuclear weapons so
the the nuclear enterprise is a key
component to our national security and
has driven competition underground in a
way that
department of defense hasn't really
aligned itself
nor has the federal government or even
the american people
part of this equation this the existence
of nuclear weapons the need to
protect the nation from direct armed
conflict uh by countries like china or
russia
is something that americans need to know
about and then
they also need to know about that you
know the
because of the existence of nuclear
weapons that their schools
uh their political systems their local
politics or state politics their
companies
are all subject to essentially attack
by the chinese communist party because
of that so what i want to explore today
is you know what is going on in this in
the nuclear enterprise
what are the challenges the nuclear
enterprise faces
um i understand uh having lived
this that dod is not focused on the
nuclear
mission as much as it used to be during
the cold war
but yet it maintains a pivotal
uh part of our overall defense so
what are the challenges and and where do
you see
the department of defense meeting those
challenges and where do you see them
where they still have work to do
well i i think
that the greatest challenge is to
have a truthful
and robust
discussion of the nuclear enterprise
really talked about those folks who
you know i i get it if if
you wish there was a world without
nuclear weapons i do too
uh but and so do i right
we all do but you cannot unring that
bell
so the
uh i also think arms control can be a
good thing
uh but we we
have to i i think we have to go back to
uh in and really
get off of these tangents that we go on
you know well we can't afford
uh so many billion dollars in this you
know
and of course uh this is something that
really
is irritating is folks who
make the affordability argument
uh are are
this is not a budget discussion it's a
discussion of priorities
and while the defense department says
that the nuclear enterprise is the
number one thing their actions don't
display
that that's that's the way it is if they
did
then we would proceed on these programs
as we are and uh
understand that uh there
is a a need to try
to make them as affordable as possible
but that does not mean that we
alter the product we alter the process
so that we do not waste money in the
process
but we still need the result now
for for example a year ago we
we were talking uh folks like you and me
were talking about the fact that
isn't it great that we have a nuclear
posture
review a national defense strategy
and a national military strategy all
aligned
in saying that nuclear weapons
are a necessary focal point of
of our defense posture and
that we need to focus our attention
on the primary competitors
in in that area being russia
and china as well as the
often said lesser uh nuclear competitors
north korea and iran
we leave out of the discussion other
nuclear-capable
nations but because they
are somewhat aligned with our point of
view we don't consider them major
competitors
so i i i suppose
to get back to your question what the
major challenge is
is uh is to is to uh
keep from talking out of both sides of
our mouths
we have people that publish articles all
the time now you see them almost
daily that are knocking the nuclear
enterprise one way or the other
and they they uh and i think
that some of the most recent ones are
actually intellectually dishonest
in that they first of all they say we
don't need them
we don't need the missiles we have
enough
nuclear weapons and other other uh
systems this
goes back to we we talked about this at
our very first symposium if you'll
recall
that i think we make the mistake of
thinking
uh that other nations other folks
see things the same way we do and they
don't
we have plenty of evidence that they
don't they don't look at the same thing
our allies don't look at things exactly
the same way we do
and a good example is is the north
korean situation
you know japan and south korea
are two of our closest allies
but that's not a threesome they have
different
concerns and relationships with each
other
with north korea and with china and
it's it's very difficult
to articulate the
point that what is enough uh
nuclear deterrence because it's in the
eye of the beholder you know it doesn't
matter what
chairman smith thinks what matters what
putin thinks
uh and it doesn't matter uh
these these writers uh the thing that
that irritates me and for the first time
i've spoken out publicly about it
is they're not accountable to anyone you
know they can say whatever they want to
but everyone we talk to are either
accountable
to their their company their
employer to the department of defense or
the department of energy
or the government we're accountable for
what we see
so uh that's a long-winded answer to
your question but the biggest challenge
is conveying the information accurately
in my opinion well but so i mean i i
agree that is a challenge but there are
some
challenges that you alluded to with
regard to budget priorities
and in particular what i was getting at
is the requirement that we have
to modernize the nuclear enterprise
and the fact that these letters that
you're referring to letters to the
editor
op-eds what have you and and different
communications all have the singular
goal of eliminating the budget for
modernization of the nuclear enterprise
so
given the fact that we're going to send
you know billions of dollars
i think it's over a trillion dollars on
the f-35 procurement
but f-35s don't keep the
chinese communist party at bay don't
keep the russians at bay
don't keep the uh north koreans at bay
as much as nuclear weapons do and so
what we're talking about here is how the
dod
spends its money what it prioritized
and and today we know that we these
systems were built in the 50s and 60s
now they've been maintained but it's
time to it's time to modernize so
can you just go through the the key
acquisition programs that need to get
funded and how you know
the triad works together almost
collaboratively to create a deterrence
that
is meaningful to our adversaries
well the the
biggest part of the problem in my
opinion is that
everything's been put off too long to
the fact that
now we have to deal with all three major
systems at the same time
that is the submarines have
have uh just
they've been extended beyond their
proposed extent
of proposed useful life when they when
they were created
so the columbia-class submarine is an
absolute necessity
to maintain that leg of the triad and
even folks who want to get rid of one
leg of the triad or the other
don't want to get rid of that one so
there there's a priority
that's staring us right in the face then
we get to the
the bombers uh i think that
we are on target uh as i understand
uh the information that i've read
uh we're both on time and on budget with
the b-21
and i think that the
path looks fairly clear for that
becoming a a
replacement for the
b-52 which is uh i guess the newest ones
we're flying now were built in the 60s
and then the uh not in 1960
and 61 to be precise yeah 1960 1961
um the b1s uh
uh you know have been converted uh
and are no longer nuclear capables so
while they're part of our bomber force
and been used extensively in the uh
in the middle east uh
they they're flying beyond their
proposed
useful lives and they've been extended
uh somewhat just so that we can maintain
a force for
conventional uh warfare
and of course the the one element that
the bomber does within the nuclear
enterprise
is posturing and the b1 helps with that
even though they're not nuclear cable
it's a big bomber that we can put
anywhere in the world we want
can you can you just briefly uh tell
people what posturing
is because they wouldn't understand that
well
this is um uh
this is to demonstrate to
allies and potential adversaries
our capability and i think uh
maybe the the the best way we had for a
while
as you know a continuous bomber presence
in
the indo-pacific region primarily
uh rotating b-1s b-52s
and b-2s to guam but that's
that's been changed and now we have a
concept called bomber tax force
and this is a little different this this
way we just put a bomber anywhere in the
world we want to whatever we want to
and if we want to and so our our
adversaries can see that
uh with satellite uh photographs
and that's uh and we can also generate
these
aircraft on alert and so if the
president says
we have a problem with something and he
wants to demonstrate resolve
generating the amount of alerters
something that can be observed by
satellite
and our adversaries can know that we
mean business that's what that's what
you mean by posturing
yes sir yes sir that's it and and uh
that that is a a unique
uh capability that uh
uh uh you know without firing a shot
you make a statement and and and that's
extremely helpful in
international relationships be able to
do that it's helpful to our allies
uh to demonstrate that they can exercise
with uh with our bombers as we recently
did with
uh someone went to portugal and then
went to the
the north atlantic uh we uh
we have uh bombers uh in in guam and
they can fly over
japan and and so yeah
that's exactly what we mean by posturing
and i think that's an important element
of the
bomber force is to demonstrate its
capability
uh with without uh
without risk without risk
of of uh of conflict but
just to show right and it's a way to
um use uh nuclear weapons
uh as a sort of psychological weapon
it's it's not a kinetic weapon it's a
weapon that's used to
impact the minds of the leaders of our
adversaries to
to let them know that something um is
important to us
it's to help them understand reality and
to help them do the right thing
so then uh the the third
leg of course is uh uh
the ground-based strategic deterrent
and uh i
wish the heck they would think of a name
for that i don't really care what it is
but most people know that as icbms
yeah okay this is the replacement for
the minutemen uh
and you know they can call it minute man
four or minute man
six or minute man x
or or whatever they want to call it uh
it's just awfully hard for people to
understand the acronym
but the it's the replacement icbm
and uh that too
is going forward it's not an upgrade and
it's not a a
not a modernization of a system
it is a new system to replace the old
one
and then
that too is costly
the the other thing which i think is a
challenge
uh rob in in that is when we're talking
about budget
you started this part of the
conversation with that is the skinny
defense budget
or the flat defense budget
which is another misnomer there's no
such thing as a skinny budget
it skinny budget
implies you know you keep what you got
and you don't
you don't expand but what it really
means is
you have less to work with because
uh as you know everything we do this
year
cost us more than it did 10 years ago in
fact it cost us more than it did a year
ago
and the inflation with our in our
economy
uh affects our our defense uh cost uh
you know as as
wages increase
the cost of everything we buy increases
and when you're talking about big
programs with
billions of dollars well then uh a
relatively modest percentage increase
consists
can be several billion dollars that of
course is one of the
other things that um uh
the naysayers you know they will
they will utilize whichever uh
uh is the most impactful you know but
30 billion dollars more you know and
what they leave off is
the uh for the next 30 years
you know if so anybody would think 30
billion dollars is a lot of money but
when it's in the context of a budget
that is in the seven to 800 billion
dollar range
then you get a picture of what we're
talking about and i think that's
that's really the issue here and that is
this is a vital element of our defense
it forces china russia north korea and
iran
to look for other ways to undermine our
society whether it be through
cyber whether it be through financial or
economic means whether it be through
political subversion or
influence through propaganda or social
media these are the ways that
these countries choose to attack our
system and our way of life and they do
that precisely because they
fear direct military conflict because of
the presence of nuclear
weapons so it's really about
prioritizing defense
understanding in the 21st century how
nations choose to go to war
particularly against a nuclear-armed
opponent
and recognizing that you know the way
we've structured our priorities
the way we've structured the protection
of our homeland
is not aligned with the way our
adversaries
are choosing to fight now we found out
in iraq and afghanistan that if you
don't have nuclear weapons it's pretty
easy
for the u.s military to come in and do
things
however we as we know with china and
russia and north korea that nuclear
weapons
changes the game and it changes it in
fundamental ways
and unfortunately you know since the end
of the cold war
where we were focused on the nuclear
enterprises and really focused on
competition uh in in preventing soviet
active measures from happening in our
society
we were much more aligned with a
different way of thinking about the
military budget and priorities
and in particular we focus on
funding the nuclear enterprise and
really
use the discretionary spending in our
budget
to invest in science and technology stem
education
infrastructure things like the
eisenhower national highway
system and manufacturing so we were
building the industrial
capability of this nation while at the
same time we were
deterring direct nuclear conflict with
our adversaries we abandoned that
at the end of the cold war in
anticipation
that you know the the the uh this
disagreement between democracy and
authoritarianism
had been resolved and everybody was
going to play well together
and you know that became this embrace of
china so that they would adopt our
uh you know liberal democratic order and
of course we know that they haven't done
that
not only have they not done that both
russia and china have been investing in
in their nuclear enterprise
so what the strategic deterrent
coalition is attempting to do
and and what i think is is a noble
effort is to educate the american people
on the fact that
the people in washington dc don't
actually
understand national security in the way
that they should we used to and in fact
eisenhower who set us on this path of
ending the soviet union really put in
place
a thinking about national security that
sure
permeate that should permeate all of our
discussions with regard to defense and
in fact one famous thing
that he said upon his
leaving office was beware the undue
influence of the military industrial
complex so this is
you know in my mind one of the key
statements he made
that supported the strategy that he had
which is
let's focus on deterrence let's build
the economic
prosperity of america let's make sure
that
americans have the capacity to have a
job
own a home and make a better life for
their kids
and over time our system will beat all
the other systems
because it's the right system what we've
done
instead is basically adopt
into our midst you know authoritarian
regimes like china and russia
gave them assets to our society our
factories our technology
and but we've but we've kept this
nuclear enterprise
and it's been there it's been protecting
us it's been preventing direct military
conflict between a rising china
more belligerent russia and the united
states
even though we've basically discounted
it
in washington d.c so i mean this is
i think um a huge a huge
um topic we ought to it ought to be at
the
you know top level of what the secretary
of defense thinks about
but i guarantee you and i saw it when i
was there
he's spending time thinking about
afghanistan he's thinking about iraq
he's thinking about the islands in the
south china sea
and and you know the naval forces and we
don't have enough f-35s and
we need so many more brigade combat
teams and he's not
thinking about the one thing that
prevents us from having
the 100 million casualties we had during
world war
ii and the 30 to 40 million casualties
we had during world war one
and so these two catastrophic wars
really have since the arrival of nuclear
weapons have been
transformed the nature of warfare and
the nature of casualties that you see in
warfare
because of this tendency for large
belligerents that are nuclear armed
not to go to direct military conflict
because they're worried about the
consequences
of that and so um you know i think
i support obviously the strategic
current coalition i just support what
you
do i think there's one other area you
mentioned the triad and the triad
you know works together to ensure that
any one leg um can't
you know it it works together to support
a comprehensive deterrent effect the
icbms that exist in our heartland
mean that any adversary would have to
directly attack the american homeland to
take them out
the subs are hidden the bombers are a
very visible show of force so where as
we
modernize that triad it's important that
we understand
why we have a triad and the role that
each leg of that triad plays
but there's a key component that you
haven't talked about and it's one that
it's near and dear to my heart because i
think it's it's integrated with the
overall challenges we face in the united
states from a cyber perspective
and from an emp perspective and that is
nuclear command and control
and the fact that that's probably the
oldest
unwritten leg or unknown leg of the
triad that is completely in the past
and today we have very little capability
in terms of modernization so
talk a little bit about nuclear command
and control because that to me i think
is
is one of the key pieces of this overall
puzzle
well uh this gets back to my early point
we're
really difficult to talk about something
that's both complicated
and and heavily classified
the best explanation i've heard recently
is
nc3 nuclear command
and control not a thing
it's a system of systems
and it is probably best to find
is how we better communicate with each
other
i i think the way i understand it is
one of the difficulties we've had in the
fighter world is
the f-22 couldn't talk to some of the
other fighters
uh and they they worked a whole lot of
that so it's the communications between
the systems
well it becomes especially important in
the
nuclear enterprise when you're talking
about the triad
and you're talking about different
weapons uh
uh systems you you're talking about
uh in different weapons
uh and different platforms
and all of this to be coordinated
so that so that the president has
options in the event of a crisis
and all of that information needs to be
pulled together
in a in a really fast succinct
form in order to make an informed
decision
so it's not quite like having a nuclear
button
but it's it's like having all of the
information
so that all the options are on the table
and that's the way i i would
try to explain what in c3 now
what have we done about that with all of
the work that's going on
with the the triad the modernization
with each leg of the triad
uh the prior secretary of one of the
prior secretaries of defense
put the responsibility on the shoulders
of
u.s stratcom to handle this
to figure this out uh and they're doing
so
and from what i understand they're
making great progress
and that's pulling all the pieces
together
and that that's uh i trust that's the
way you look at it that's what nc3 is
pulling the pieces together so that all
the facts are in front of us
so that the national command authority
has uh all of the options
ready available whether
something needs to be done so it's an
extremely part
extremely strong and important part
of the whole modernization of the
nuclear enterprise
because as new systems and weapons come
on
there's more to be integrated than in
the past
and as do systems and weapons come on
that are managed the systems are managed
in a different way
it's kind of we're converting from a
analog information system to digital
that would be one way i would i would
try to describe it uh
is that makes sense from a layman's uh
explanation of
nc3 well i think the way that i would uh
i would describe it is it's basically
the system that allows the president to
pick up the phone and and have
what he wants to have happen have
happened um
now as you know one of the ways that
john warden talked about warfare was
thinking about the five
rings and you know going after
the ability of the commander
of a force to not communicate with
forces is a key component of that
of that strategy and so um in many
respects nuclear command and control
becomes the most important part of
the nuclear enterprise because to the
extent the
president has cut off from
communications with his forces
that would be a very very bad day
i think that the other issue that's
really not well understood by the
american people
is that nuclear command and control was
the last
and only system uh that was ever
created to withstand the high altitude
nuclear burst
and today uh our world you know
our digital world the world of
smartphones
is not hardened against high altitude
nuclear bursts and i think this is
this is an area where um what is
happening in nuclear command and control
can inform how the rest of the united
states
uh particularly on the on the public
side should think about
infrastructure in other words
if you could shut the lights out
with one high altitude nuclear burst
over the united states
you wouldn't necessarily uh harm anybody
physically with a nuclear weapon but you
would shut out
the lights you'd turn off all the
smartphones
and essentially uh in in a matter of
hours we'd be like katrina from
west to east coast and i so i think
about
this quite a lot particularly in the
context of
not so much russia and china but
a rogue regime like north korea or maybe
iran that could get a weapon
and one weapon could create enormous
defestation in the united states
because of the vulnerability and the
requirement of our society
to have these smartphones and and
everything to do everything from
banking to you know have medical
treatment now because
of telemedicine and everything it's it's
a vital
part of our national security and
when we think about nuclear command and
control we're thinking about the
hardening of those systems
for that kind of attack but that doesn't
extend to the population
that doesn't mean that we're protecting
the american people
from shutting the lights out now i
wonder
you know what the president would say if
uh
his chief of staff walked in one day and
said mr president i have good news
and bad news the good news is you still
have
full control and command over all your
nuclear forces
the bad news is no american cell phone
will work
no lights will come on no bank transfers
are happening
the country from a digital perspective
is shut down mr president
what are your orders
so um joe this has been a a great
conversation
i i i think my um the audience is going
to love
what you have to say it's something that
they don't get
every day and your commitment to the
nation as a patriot
is something that you know every
american should applaud
you know americans serve in many ways
they serve in uniform
they serve in businesses and they serve
as
civic leaders like you have and and i
want to thank you for your
patriotism for your support thank you
for being on
generally spa generally speaking thank
you rob
great to see you great to see you